- I understand you have
a young one at home
and you had to help him with homework.
How did that go? And I
think I know the answer.
- My boyfriend has two kids,
he has seven year old twins.
So, while I am not fully
responsible for them,
I did sort of dive in when
the homeschooling started.
(sighs)
I mean, I have teachers in my family.
Teachers, I've always
considered to be wildly valuable
but now more than ever, it's very clear
that what they do is just so needed
because not a great teacher.
- Not great at it either. (laughs)
- Not great.
I mean, there are just things
that you just sort of take for
granted as an adult, I think,
and talking to my boyfriend's son,
I was like, it's spelled L-I-G-H-T.
I don't know why, it just is.
- It just is and it
doesn't make any sense.
- It's so strange, we just-
- I don't know why there
are that many there's.
I don't know why.
- We just gotta go with it, kid.
So yeah, so I was not... I mean, I tried.
We got a little better by the end
and now that summer's started,
it's more just about reading
and maintaining what they were doing.
- And just keeping them entertained
so they don't drive
you nuts, yes. (laughs)